we have always been caught up in the
anticipation of the unspeakable the
human adventure has always been a
flirtation with these gigantic forces in
an unseen dimension this is what sets
our religions going this is what creates
gurus and messiahs and scientific
breakthroughs it's that somehow we are
in resonance with something much larger
than ourselves something which you could
call the Great Attractor the
transcendental object at the end of time
but I am mine whatever it is we out of
all of nature's seem to have a special
relationship to it and seem to be
somehow both under its care and somehow
involved in the manifesting of it in
three-dimensional space it's that as we
make our way across the historical
landscape toward the sensed presence of
this transcendental other so it is
making its way toward us through the
content of dreams psychedelic
experiences of the careers of
spiritually advanced people the ID of
the
that history which is the state of
extreme instability of his equilibrium
which only lasts 15
that history is about to be transformed
or ended that the factors that shaped
history phonetic alphabets male
dominance materialism scientific method
empiricism these factors are about to be
made obsolete by discoveries in the
human and natural realm